on the heat summer is here and so is our
friend john mccarthy from don's corner
with some great tips when it comes to
summer beauty you're back in studio i'm
so happy that you're here
we have got some amazing products i am
like infatuated with every single one
and let's talk about this first one
because
i need a tan really bad you are a little
white for me i have a lot of white and
so this is a tan in a can explain again
this is southseaskincare.com
don't try to say that 10 times fast
south sea skin care so this is their
mist that's one of my favorite products
from the line this is a line that you
was on dancing with the stars i believe
for over 18 season that's how they got
this sun kiss glow and so did i i think
a great place to put them is on your arm
your body it kind of gives you that
really beautiful glow okay i'm going to
try to go seriously immediately six
inches apart okay about six inches all
right go ahead and spray oh look at that
it smells it's not sticky that's a
pretty nice it's not orange not orange
and you can just rub it in and buff it
out can i take this yes that one is
yours to take home with you and it'll
give you that sunkissed glow
again they're all have good tahitian
oils and everything in them that's a
really good for your skin like i said
they have an entire line they have
mousses if you want a darker color
smells like coconut i go with this
hydrating mist everyone i kind of do
even your clavicles sometimes to kind of
make them stand out and look really
pretty when you go out at night but your
legs anytime you have a little missing
area this is kind of my go-to and like
if it's good enough for dancing with the
stars it's good enough yeah for sure i
love that one okay speaking of dancing
with the stars and glamour and they
always have these beautiful lashes now
we can get those beautiful lashes yes so
this is magnetic mom lash and what i
love about this company is they're
cruelty free they're really simple to
put on and it gives you that little pop
and you can wear them for up to 30 times
so you're going to get 30 where's out of
this and it comes you've got the little
liner there so during covet and lockdown
i didn't know how to put on lashes so
this is how i learned because i can put
a lash line like i knew how to make an
eyeliner on my lash but i didn't really
know how to you know put the lashes i'd
end up with the glue all over my lid and
stuff not with this system when they're
magnetic they just go on they're easy to
come off they stick to the liner they
stick to the liner that's okay it's just
magnetic and she gives back she's got an
m cause that gives back to cancer
patients which is near and dear to my
heart because i lost my mom to cancer
when i was young so it's a really good
product it's a really good price point
last it's about 30 dollars you get 30
wears and again they're just kind of a
fun go-to that you can take on and off
really quick and you don't have to be a
makeup artist i love that we have one
minute left i want to get to all these
things so this is try snow this is like
you've seen the kardashians everyone
talking about it and you guys have magic
mike but i have the magic strips so
these are dissolving strips because it's
the summer time we want to have that
beautiful bright white smile out there
for everyone to see and right here
you're just going to put it on and it's
actually going to dissolve on your teeth
within 15 minutes you just peel that off
you put it on your teeth it's got a
great peppermint it's really good so if
you have sensitive teeth you don't have
to worry about it you'll just put it on
you can barely see it so when you're in
your car when you're on the way from the
radio station to the station you can
just put them on or after you do your
makeup in the morning they'll just go
she loves it
but they have a complete system with
mouthwashes all types of stuff they'll
just stay on they're just going to
dissolve you don't have that wig it's so
crazy exactly they don't have gunk or
anything on them like other ones did and
again i think you get 28 strips for
under 30 dollars everything's blasted
quickly
this is secret's new weightless dry
spray this is the wild rose we smelled
it earlier it's going to give you 48
hours of protection i better do it under
here
a little bit
of odor and sweat protection this is a
must during the summer because we don't
want to smell we just want to look good
you can get them at drug stores or
retailers nationwide under seven dollars
but deodorant is key to have and again
you want all that time and again there's
no residue no white residue no waxes
none of that stuff on your system great
stuff again don's corner thank you so
much we will be right back and you still
got the strips on